the tour season is about to begin and
workers at the ions edo museum a park in
over Laos it's are putting the final
touches on the parts latest attractions
how about spending the night in a tree
house or relaxing in this eco-friendly
health spa creative director Juergen
bagman hopes ideas like these attract
more visitors to this rural region good
cvn with others everything here has to
be professional enough to work last year
we came up with this idea of an old
Slavic health spa and it really caught
on so now we're making it more
professional which makes sense from a
business perspective up to 10 people can
sit together in the cannibal cauldron
and simmer away in candy bar in
castleton let's go gaga over Laos it's
is unknown outside of Germany despite
its picturesque landscapes and charming
architecture like here in the city of
Belton population 40,000 the town is
decked out for spring all that's missing
are the tourists Felton's mayor spent
years living in China and brings
international flair to the city he says
Belson needs to market itself
goodness tema when it comes doubts and
most people think of the prison and some
about mustard and that's it we're one of
Germany's most beautiful cities in the
old town has been completely preserved
it's an incredibly strong economic
region and well worth seeing but almost
nobody is aware of that so we have a lot
to do I need is not would the mayor
hopes local sorbian traditions will
attract more visitors that dance
ensemble has already performed in 45
countries around the world now the city
hopes fans will come to over Laos it's
the head of tourism sees a lot of
potential in sorbian culture
dannon it has a great cultural value as
well as a long tradition and we Germans
and sorbs want to cultivate that but it
has to be done in a way that helps
develop tourism in our region it's a
unique selling point with a lot of
promise good selfish patiently back at
the ions you to amusement park
executives are pinning their hopes on
increased tourism but they understand
that's not enough at the parts on
woodworking shop there now busy creating
attractions for amusement parks in
France and Germany a production makes us
special we travel with it throughout
Europe and produce for other amusement
parks it accounts for around three
quarters of our revenue last year was
about four and a half million euros so
it's quite large I'm key to our company
should only cause an opening on this
understand by the next major project is
an adventurer hotel for a Chinese
investor such deals are the only way to
continue financing the amusement park